[موسيقى]
احنا اطفال فلسطين كبرنا قبل
اوانا احنا بنكبر بالوجع مش بعدد السنين
نتحدث عن 91% من الاطفال في قطاع غزه
يعانون من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه وهذه نسبه
مخيفه بشكل اساسي يعني نتحدث عن نحو جميع
الاطفال في قطاع غزه صواريخ بموتوا الناس
ققطع لهم رجليهم زي بابا وزي
[موسيقى]
الناس اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه اي ان الشخص
يت ترض لخبره صادمه مفاجئه خارجه عن نطاق
خبراته الشخصيه وتشكل تهديد على كيانه
حياته ولديها استجابات على المستوى
المعرفي والجسدي والنفسي والسلوكي
الاعتداء المتكرر وعدم الاستقرار الذي
يولده لدى المجتمع الغزي هل تعتقد بانه
امر عبثي ام ان هناك حربا نفسيه ممنهجه
حقيقيه موازيه للحرب العسكريه في الفتره
ما قبل العدوان لم يكن هناك شعور بالامان
اطلاقا لدى اطفال المجتمع تسعه من كل ع
اطفال لا يشعرون بالامان في غياب ذويهم
بالنسبه للكبار الاشكاليه ان ثلثي الاباء
يتحدثوا عن عدم قدرتهم
على يعني لا يشعرون بانهم قادرون على
مساعده ابنائهم على تغطيه احتياجات
ابنائهم بالذات اثناء عدم شعورهم بالامان
هذه الاحصائيات وهذه الارقام بالتاكيد هي
اكثر من قدرات اي جهاز صحي في اي مكان
[موسيقى]
بالعالم
رمضان ما الذي يمكن ان تقوله لاطفال غزه
واطفال العالم عن اطفال غزه هذا العدو
بعرفش الا القتل والغدر وزي ما بقول
الشاعر تميم البرغوتي كل العدو يا اراك
احمق ما
تزال فالان ا فوضهم على ما شئت واطلب منهم
وقف
القتال يا قائد النفر الغزه
جديله او الى العين الكحيله من
سنين ادري بانك لا تخاف الطفل
حيا انما ادعوك صدقا ان تخاف من الصغار
[موسيقى]
الميتين